jennifer lopez has made it official with
ben affleck and it seems like she wants
everyone to know it
i'm so excited on monday the triple
threat was seen strutting the streets of
monaco
sporting a stylish white dress fedora
patterned mask
and this gold necklace that spells out
b-e-n
it's this beautiful freeing kind of
loving feeling of course this comes
after ben and jen went instagram
official over the weekend
j-lo posted this steamy photo of them as
they celebrated her 52nd birthday on
this luxurious
yacht 52 yes
give it to him yeah
hello hello
and of course benifer's seaside
rendezvous didn't stop there
fashion blogger rebel needa tells et j
lo's b day celebration went into the
night they were spotted enjoying a
dinner at lopez ain't trapeze
where the couple quote looked very happy
and were kissing throughout the night
and looked super in love i think we had
chemistry
as actors from the first moment we
started working
rebel also goes on to say ben and jlo
felt very comfortable and had the time
of their life with the crazy personal
birthday show
that lopeea put on for them they got a
lot of attention
but they seemed to love it but ben and
jen aren't the only ones living it up in
san tropez
j lo's ex alex rodriguez is also
enjoying his own yacht weekend in france
level up level up level up level up
level up
and now a source tells e.t that alex and
j.lo being in the same place
is really just a coincidence saying
quote alex is there enjoying time with
family and friends on a yacht
it's for you nick oh god
oh in april the former power couple
announced that after a two-year
engagement in four years of dating
they decided to call it quits another
source tells et when they first split
he wanted to work things out and still
held on to hope that he and jlo would
get back together
he's come to terms with the fact that
it's over now she's
really funny and amazing and she's just
magical she you know she everything she
touches is just
i've learned so much from her